[Musique]
comprendre ce qui se passe autour de vous
vous êtes en état de guerre et vous avez
peu de temps précieux pour vous sauver
[Musique]
est un processus lent que nous appelons des mesures actives
la première étape étant la démoralisation
il faut de 15 à  20 ans pour
démoraliser la nation
la prochaine étape est la déstabilisation
ce qui compte c'est l'essentiel l'économie
les relations extérieures les systèmes de défense
la prochaine étape est la crise
avec un changement violent de la structure du pouvoir
et de l'économie période de normalisation
c'est ce qui se passera aux
états-unis si vous permettez tout  ces schmucks
pour mettre un grand gouvernement plus large à
washington dc
nous promettrons beaucoup de choses peu
importe que les promesses soient tenues
ou non
[Applaudissements]
la bombe à retardement fait tic tac mais chaque
seconde
la catastrophe se rapproche de plus en plus
le danger est réel
vous